thank you uh yes sir yes we are here
indeed with michael kodakowski the
executive director of the grand chester
and one of the masterminds behind this
global project michael welcome to our
studio first of all tell us a bit about
this tournament the superbath chess
classic how do you assess it from a
viewer's perspective as well as from an
organizer's perspective i think
both uh
very well run on one end and very well
played on another so i think uh
players
uh met all expectations and we're
basically to the wire and very possible
that we're going to have tie break
so therefore i think organizers are
happy spectators are happy and people
keep coming to see the action
until the end of the day and tell us a
bit about the selection process because
one thing that strikes me about this
tournament is the eclectic mix of young
talent as well as experienced players
and of course four candidates tell us
about that
that's our goal
first of all we have top players
and of course to bring
young guns to give opportunity for young
aspiring players who already showed
good skills and good results in
different tournaments
not necessarily their welcome to any
other tournaments therefore we give wild
cards to to those
who may perform well and actually be
recognized and especially here in
romania we have a couple of interesting
youngsters and one of them is bogdan
diack
and
last year he played here
and he did well
as well as this one and right now he's
playing last round against fabiana and i
think that he will finish on 50
very decent result and i'm sure that
romanian
chess community will be
very happy to see that
now one thing that helps us bring all
these amazing players here in bucharest
as well as all the other uh stuffs of
the tour is the partnerships that you
guys are creating now a big one is with
the superbad foundation tell us about
that as well as all the local sponsors
that you guys have engaged for this year
yeah super bad foundation became our
major partner in europe
and they sponsoring all
all three events
in uh in europe uh zagreb warsaw and uh
zagreborsa and of course bucharest
and uh because of that
obviously they have
aspirations
to be
probably a
capital
uh
of europe if saint louis chess club is a
national capital of chess in the united
states i'm sure that bucharest may
become a capital of europe
and
obviously
armenian
players
only have more opportunities for growth
and i just met during the course of this
tournament
i met
several youngsters
i even played some games with them i
visited school where we
established the program so
little by little
uh
bucharest and romania become uh
i would say right now big hop
for european chess michael you've
mentored so many young aspiring chess
players how important is it for these
young romanian players as well as polish
and croatian young players to see the
best of the best compete face to face
well you know i remember my youth
and
of course every tournament that
we attended and we
saw
uh
legends with so our heroes on stage
playing it was aspiring
we certainly wanted to be
at least one of them if not all of them
and obviously we have
our own heroes maybe to follow
but it is very inspiring
and
seeing here many youngsters from the
opening ceremony playing simultaneous
exhibitions and visiting day by day
every round
you can see that it's big interest and
it's uh
factor
of future of cheers in romania
absolutely as this tournament finishes
we're getting ready to uh go to warsaw a
new stop in the grand chess tour how did
that came about and what are your
expectations for that stop of the tour
well it would be first time and again
it's because super bad foundation uh
has its offices in uh um
in poland
and they decided to open new
stuff for us on the tour
and uh having uh duda and voy tashak
playing especially dude there is another
another candidate for uh
for the world championship cycle it
would be very excited for uh polish
crowd and uh i know for sure it would be
packed
well i love the fact that a competition
almost feels like brewing between
romania warsaw and all these stuffs
trying to establish themselves as the
european capital of chess now
to finalize this interview i would like
to ask your opinion about the games
today michael we know that we do have a
draw and of course i want to ask your
opinion about this one how do you see
the position does wesley have any
chances of actually winning this one out
right
well you know it's hard to say whether
he will be able to win outright but
definitely he will be pushing for that
because this is the chance for him to
win uh first leg and grab first prize
and uh
uh
bonus point towards grand chess tour so
this game will continue
you know he will be pushing and as we
were uh entering the interview you also
mentioned this game and and we are
potentially trying to do something in
his game against ali rezab what do you
think of this well uh two
two frenchmen
are playing uh against each other
obviously
each of them wants to win
for uh for maxime it's opportunity to
catch up with uh
um
leaders
and potentially so and it would be
three-way tie
and that would be even more exciting to
see along a long saturday night
cheers
and
again this
this tournament
showed us that
nerves are
not very steady
uh for for the chess players there were
some blunders here is very dynamic
balanced position and
we might see some excitement this type
of uh
exciting chess is exactly what we are
looking forward to seeing these type of
events thank you very much michael for
joining us and we'll see you soon in
poland of course
guys back to you
thank you christian thank you michael
and let's just jump in